thank you guys so much super pumped to
be here
quick little six-hour flight this
keynote and take a red-eye home tonight
so hustling look I think there's a lot
that I want to cover
I see the mics here so I definitely want
to do some Q&A during this talk as well
I've been getting some context to the
audience makeup and so obviously a very
entrepreneurial crowd there's a lot
going on it seems like a good amount of
you have some context for me I'm sure
some of you don't but what I really want
to speak about is really just the
current state of things right like the
thing that I think will index for
anybody in this room whether today's
your first day or you've been in it for
a while whether you're in a b2b
environment a b2c environment trying to
build your personal brand trying to sell
homes trying to start an app whatever it
may be I want to really kind of go on
the things that I see that are happening
that will bring the most value and I
think through QA we'll go into the stuff
that brings more individual value and I
encourage you to be selfish when you get
up here and ask your questions I think
the place to start with a healthy mix
here of of young faces and some that are
not as young along with my face that is
not as young is the following which is
for the 20 year old crowd in here the
early 30 year old crowd there's a lack
of context of realizing how special the
environment we are in is because it's
the only one you've ever known
this is what you've grown up you've
grown up in this environment you've
grown up with the internet and and
there's a lack of understanding of how
ridiculously big this is on the other
hand the people that have been
successful for 10 15 20 30 years there's
an understanding that all this new stuff
is different but there is the cliche
fear and curiosity versus the
tried-and-true that is super interesting
and so for me the thing that I want to
really drill home in my opening
statements is the following I really
need this audience to understand that we
are a block
we fortunate to be in this position
right this minute because actually this
is fun because I know there's a lot of
real estate DNA here I genuinely view
what's happening on the internet right
now similar to when some of the great
cities somebody bought up New York for
[ __ ] nothing and when I mean nothing
I mean dollars not millions or 100 that
there was human beings who actually
bought and I don't even know you know
this is where I wish I did a little
better in school but like the Louisiana
Purchase was a [ __ ] steal and and and
I actually genuinely think that that's
what's happening on the internet right
now now I think it's ten years in the
consumer internet that I'm passionate
about is really only twenty years old it
was really Windows 95 that got normal
people to figure out how to get onto the
Internet
it was a o L right it's really only
twenty years but the web 2.0 into social
media internet is really only a decade
old and I think everybody here now
whether it's the presidential election
or brexit or the Arab Spring or
something that happened in your family
amongst eight people I think everybody
realizes now unlike a decade ago when I
was talking about this that this is big
[ __ ] that this is not some little cable
TV extension of Maine TV this is not
some sad you know that's going to be
around for a little bit this is the
fundamental shift of how human beings
interact with each other which is the
currency of our lives and so I guess the
thing that I'm trying to frame up for a
lot of you right now is I don't think
this room including myself actually
understands how big of an opportunity
this is in whatever you care about you
sit in this room as I do today caring
about business aspects of your life but
this goes far beyond that I mean we're
in a world now where just ten years ago
if you did online dating you were weird
and awkward and lived in your mom's
basement and now and now it's the only
way people do it
like we need to understand how big this
really is because when you start
understanding that this is oxygen that
this is oxygen that this in its current
form and soon contact lenses when
everything is virtual reality or AR or
AI or wherever it goes that this is our
currency literally so many of you would
struggle to function without your cell
phone by your side would you would you
would not realize the detox that you
would actually go through if you didn't
have your phone you run to the Apple
store run to the Apple store when you
lose or break your phone you cry for the
four-hour delay that you have to wait so
and by the way many of you are going to
sit as I say this right now and think
it's sad I don't
I think it's evolution I don't think
it's that I really don't I think it's
nothing I think it's the thing I think
people thought a lot of things were sad
like the television and the telephone
and the car people thought things are
sad always when it wasn't what they grew
up with right there's people that said
you know they always think it's not
important until it becomes mainstream I
grew up 41 and grew up on the East Coast
hip hop wasn't supposed to be a real
thing it is the main currency now like
like this is what always happens with
humans and so I tell you all of this
because I can get into the deep details
of what do you do on direct message on
Instagram er what does it take less
work/life balance and work ethic and how
do you do Facebook ads and all the
cliches [ __ ] that I know you're going to
ask me before but before
[Applause]
but before we get into that I really
want to get everybody if you I feel like
it's the one thing I can do for
everybody if you leave here and realize
that this is all just the beginning that
it's never going back that it's way
bigger than you think we like people he
know me every day selling eight million
dollar homes from one one Facebook ad
like this is Neal like this is we're
here like it is not coming there's not
your fourteen-year-old daughter this is
now this is what happening right now and
if you haven't wanted it there are
people in this room that haven't fully
committed to being relevant in the
mobile device for their business they're
basically not relevant they're trading
on the history of what got them here
you're trading on the word of mouth of
the people that you've done business
with in the past but that's Windows
everyday and if you have any interest
how many people in this room are
actually retiring in the next five years
and I don't mean you're going to [ __ ]
crush it and buy an island I mean you're
just [ __ ] old and you're finished how
many people five years raise your hands
love it 5.12 great for you it's an
interesting debate right can you hold on
to what got you here for next five kind
of hold on to it it'll be diminishing
returns of attention and things of that
nature there'll be other young upstarts
that activate against the opportunities
but for five years even though that's a
long time I actually think all the stuff
that I believe in the most
you could probably hold on right for
everybody else this is binary you're
basically in the same position right now
that every person that owned a bunch of
taxi medallions and black car services
did the day before
uber started for everybody else in this
room except for those two lovely people
who by the way both look pretty [ __ ]
good and I'm not so sold are completely
done in five
for everybody else you're basically the
owner of four very good bookstores in
your town the day before Amazon decided
to get serious your entire life
regardless of industry over the next
decade will be eaten up by technology
and either you're on the eating side or
you're on the other side and I don't
think most people here want to get [ __ ]
it out right right and so for me for me
this is not fun games this is like
really important because you understand
regardless of what you do in this room
regardless there's only one thing I'm
short on we all trade on the same
currency and that is attention attention
is the number one currency in our
society before you tell me how great you
are at what you do or how great your
service is or what you do or how nice
your [ __ ] dress because this crew
rolls that way before you do that you
need my attention to even be able to
tell me that and if you don't have it
you [ __ ] lost and the attention of
our society is right here and you may
think it's sad and you may not like it
but it's the punchline and the romance
of how you want it to be or how it used
to be is [ __ ] irrelevant this is
reality so now I say to myself if we all
agree that this is int right this is the
dominant place for the attention of our
consumers well then you got to start
looking at social media super
differently because social media my
friends takes up 50% of every human
beings time on this and now all of a
sudden it's not just a nice to have
or this emerging kind of thing or kind
of cute' now of a sudden it's the yellow
pages and the billboards and the bus
stop ad and the Direct Mail and the
local commercial and the TV show if
you're lucky to be one of those for real
and all of it in one place and here's
where it gets crazy
there's no gatekeepers there's nobody in
between you and the person you're trying
to reach on this platform except the
platform's itself which is why Facebook
such a big company got it and so this is
a mindset shift that 20 to 80 percent of
this room is not pot committed to this
environment even the most committed
young players and I say young just real
quick young mentality it's not an age
thing there's a bunch of 27 year olds
running around like it's 1942 and
there's a bunch of 61 year olds that
[ __ ] try everything in her [ __ ]
pot committed it's a mentality so 20 to
80 percent of the people in this world
like to me they're just not pot
committed and for me what I know
something's happening Google in the
early days which built wine library
Facebook and Instagram influencers right
now you know I'm not a poker player but
I do know this if you're the best hand
it's a good idea to go all-in and so we
have a little window here I've been
doing my thing for 20 years not forever
but long enough to know this I've only
seen it twice 2001 to 2003 Google which
oh by the way Amazon and eBay built
their entire businesses on the back of
Google underpriced attention everything
still works somebody raised their hand
online Gary I do the wreck nail it works
Mazel Tov Rick
I know that it can still work I just
also know that you can do Facebook ads
as direct mail and convert four times
more so you spent ten thousand dollars
for X and I could spend ten thousand
dollars for four XS it's not about what
doesn't work or it works anymore it's
what's under priced and what's
overpriced television commercials can
work it's just not funneled to spend a
million dollars on them today compared
to 1974 when we didn't have remote
controls and actually [ __ ] watched
them so this is what I think about this
is what I trade on and we all know it's
going only in one direction the number
one job dream of every 13 to 16 year old
in America is to be a youtuber and or an
influencer that is literally what they
want to be in their lives this is now
over that's it the amount of people that
don't have cable is staggering the
amount of people that will never get to
page 106 in a magazine to see your ad is
staggering your car's going to drive
you're anywhere you want to go for you
it's happening now this isn't coming get
a new Tesla [ __ ] does it all of it like
this is real and so what I don't think
people know and why I brought up the
five year question is if you think back
to 10 years ago we're just getting the
first iPhone yeah guys ten years ago
none of this [ __ ] existed YouTube and
Facebook or babies and are like for very
small niches
we don't have smartphones yet like where
do you think this is going so what I'm
fearful of is while you sit and debate
if you should be doing Facebook or
Instagram influencers or snapchat or
have a blog or sort of vlog or do a
podcast while you sit and debate this
minor leagues [ __ ] which is right now
the major leagues the majors are coming
what are you going to do about Alexis
skills when people like Alexa I want to
go to open houses and Alexa tells you
which open houses you're going to
and if you're not playing there where
are you right like where where are you
because what I'm most worried about is
our worried about all of your digital
DNA if you're pushing against this [ __ ]
you're really going to get ran over in
the next decade you'll never be good at
augmented reality if you weren't good at
Facebook I'm here right I'm right I mean
like how are you ever going to be ready
for the next [ __ ] if you're still
fighting this and like super pumped to
like spend your money on a [ __ ] bench
ad so I guess where my energy is clearly
going since I never really know what the
[ __ ] I'm going to talk about is is I
think the stakes are higher than you
think and I think that when you wake up
in two years and see that Ralph Lauren
Polo has gone out of business and when
you wake up in two or three years and
see that you know the game stop is out
of business like when you start seeing
it and you're seeing it right and you
could say feel it I mean any of you that
have you been to a ball lately and [ __ ]
is sad
right and like and what m1 and what does
happen there's a lot of youngsters in
here let me go into a 15 year innovation
talk what does happen when we have
self-driving cars and we actually enjoy
our commutes and all of a sudden prime
real estate is not as prime as it used
to be because all of a sudden now on
15-minute commute when you can do
everything in it all of a sudden becomes
a more interesting thing for humans to
do you guys know macro trends the cities
in this country over the last thirty
years were dead and they were surged
over the last decade because the youth
is more interested in living in the
cities because the dynamics have changed
what happens when people actually figure
out it's not a good idea to own a home
because the map is super intriguing and
the game's changing and so I really want
to push everybody to understand this is
big stakes
this isn't how am I going to build my
personal brand on Instagram Gary I don't
give a [ __ ] Ralph
this is do you actually understand the
era that you're living through like this
is the Industrial Revolution this is
like getting electricity this is big
[ __ ] and this is big [ __ ] not only in
your business life but in the dynamics
of who we are all this stuff going on
wherever you are on politics this is not
him or her this is the dynamics of media
in our society this is the dynamics of
all of us having media 24/7 this is
what's happening we're about to change
and so bringing it back to the micro
business that means a lot of money is
about to be made and a lot of money is
about to be lost and what I haven't
figured out is how many of you are
willing to draw a line in the sand and
say that you hate all this technology
stuff and aren't willing to put in the
20 hours to read and watch videos to
educate yourself out of your raw emotion
when it's going to wipe you out I think
that's awesome I think you deserve to go
directly out of business if you're not
willing to put in the work I do if if
you're wrong about what's about to
happen and you weren't willing to put in
the work you deserve to lose and so
that's what's going to happen and so I
would say this please please understand
that this is the beginning we are
definitely definitely going to live at
this point in my opinion in an augmented
reality world which means what you see
happening with snapchat and Instagram
where you have your face and then
puppies and [ __ ] Coachella things at
all that's that's about to go super far
you're all going to work you're all
going to wear contact lenses in 20 years
where you're seeing the real world an
augmented world and a virtual world on
an everyday basis blended always and
forever that's what's coming and so look
I'm just as pissed as everybody else
and I'm not looking forward to the
robots killing all of us but they're
gonna win and so we might as well enjoy
our time now and I'd like you to be on
the side of it instead of against it I'm
not super special
the reason I'm gonna win at the highest
levels is I don't fight reality a brutal
in my complete lack of romance of how it
should be and my complete investment
into how it actually is right and that's
the price sighs you know if I was the
social media came along I had digital
media figured out I was winning on email
in Google AdWords like I'd won like it
was devastating I was like [ __ ] this is
gonna work you know and and by the way
and you're gonna see it you'll watch 53
year old me completely be obsessed with
VR AR AI or whatever else that is about
to be invented I have no idea that I'm
gonna believe your attention will be and
you're all going to actually see it the
first time nobody knew who I was
this time I'm so associated with this
stuff when you see me in seven years
and whatever the Facebook feed of the
day is and the video is gonna be like
you're still doing Facebook you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they're gonna be like what
isn't that what he believes in no I
believe in creating attention in the day
that we actually live in I believe
making my actions allow me to sell what
I want to sell it
when I say sell I mean selling a home a
pair of sneakers or raising awareness
for Crohn's disease because my brother
AJ has it or raising money for the PTA
or
whatever may be selling or bringing
awareness to whatever matters to me and
as we all know what matters to today was
different than five years ago and in
five years it's going to be different
again and that's just the way it is and
so I implore you and I see a line
starting to gather so if you want to
start gathering in line because I don't
think I'll get to all of them is a good
time to start moving I implore you to
understand yes I believe in social media
B I think that's a slang term for the
current state of the internet you know
people call YouTube and LinkedIn social
media sites they are not as left there's
only one social media site left it's
called Twitter all the other ones are
just content push there's no back and
forth really in a lot of places anymore
right so that's just the word don't get
hung up on it everything you see that's
happening with me is because I'm
creating attention I believe in sound I
think every person here needs to wrap
their head around the following
statement which is this you were a media
company first and then whatever else you
do for a living you have to start
understanding that you're a media
company now that may mean and for a lot
of you it means that that's you you for
others you don't have to develop you
write the Huffington Post was an Arianna
Huffington in every post everything like
you could be the platform but you better
realize you're in the media business
because the cost of being in the media
business is now zero in distribution
opportunity and production it's so low
it's so low dirac and i did an episode
of daily be our vlog yes that came out
today
my latest vlog right now on YouTube was
all filmed on this you know so I want to
hear your [ __ ] excuses that you
don't have a [ __ ] camera or the
lighting and all this everybody's in the
[ __ ] excuse business every one of you
is running through your head right now
of why you're not in the media business
or why you're not doing this and it's
all [ __ ] it's because you have
decided not to it's binary this is
simple either you're in it or you're not
because once you make the mental
decision that you're in it maybe you
invest in a nice camera instead of
another [ __ ] see
I think it's on how are you do you guys
have to turn this on or see what happens
we go hey Gary I'm rich from Austin
number one I'm a retired attack
helicopter pilot for the Marines and I
brought a patch for you are you in here
ah can I bring it to you all right so
real quick I know there's a line so I
work full-time I don't have time to do
what I want to do yet my plan is this
another pilot and I want to get together
we want to go around to successful
veterans in all types of industries that
we know and interview them for free all
right I don't need your [ __ ] money I
don't need anything I want to show
veterans who are gonna transition
because it's incredibly difficult and
there's another problem there's also a
group of veterans I think they're
entitled as [ __ ] all right
and we need to expel both those rumors
that's right so what I want to do is go
interview and just paint the picture
like hey here's what you can be the only
thing that's not allowing me to execute
and I'm overanalyzing Danny for sure is
that I want them to be authentic it's
your take the risk everybody's scared to
waste time when time is your number one
asset that you have so go interview
Charles and then 3/4 of the way you're
like [ __ ] this guy's so full of [ __ ] and
then show it
so right so what I mean is I guess part
of the vulgarity is authenticity is what
attracted me do the holy [ __ ] I've never
seen a guy like this yeah and I don't
want them to hide behind whatever logo
they work for or whatever yeah and then
not to see the real picture I want them
to know like hey there's still that guy
or gal in uniform they're right there
yeah you know what I mean so I'm not
sure I don't know about financially can
you do it now because there's I have a
really good idea that's why I'm asking
uh I collect retirement so that's good
and then my full-time job is great I
would have limited time but my partner
and I want to go probably three or four
interviews a month can fly up to
wherever and then do what we got to do
great so I mean a your ability to get a
sponsor for this is very high like most
businesses can't get a sponsor on spec
so because of the subject matter
literally if you just cold emailed the
top 1,000 corporations in America you'd
probably make so much bond Saoirse
bloody you'd be like [ __ ] anyway I I
think I think you know I mean I don't
think that's valid what you said okay
just go do your best okay like maybe get
an extra sponsor to hire somebody to vet
people so they can really bet but like
that's not scary
because then you just don't have to show
it I don't suck to fly somewhere and it
didn't work out but you can hire an
intern or $38,000 a year employee you
could do ridiculous research on anybody
to get you 2/3 and a half base and you
watch something for 10 minutes I'm
making the decision thank you so much
[Music]
um so you did a video on sales versus
marketing yes about a month ago yeah my
question to you and you alluded to it
earlier when you said you know what
happens if people decide they don't want
to buy a house anymore
I'm in direct sales in the direct sales
for seven years and a lot of people in
this room are my question is where in
the future say five to ten years in the
future from now where are you pushing
your chips are you pushing it into sales
and sales or are you pushing it in the
marketing the reason I'm asking is you
know with Amazon and your boy Jeff Bezos
and Tesla they don't do cons and cons of
little spend comes a ton of money on
marketing or on advertising I don't
think it kind of knows I do they do okay
so my question I guess is they both work
they both work both work right if
they're different foundations and how
[ __ ] gets done you either retarget
people affiliate all the tactical ships
that sell something yeah or what is much
more interesting which is people don't
even realize why they bought the [ __ ]
they're wearing right now because they
were marketing to marketing marketing
and branding is just grown-up sales so
in the future when people are able to
buy anything they want to and just go
through an experience on their phone yes
right does that cut out the direct sales
portion of course I could okay so where
are you putting your money in five to
ten years Ford like the car industry the
home industry right I mean I think look
I think I think what the internet does
and technology does is it squeezes the
middleman out because the internet is
the middleman and so yeah I mean I think
I'm putting my money on whoever's making
[ __ ] because they're going to be able to
at a much higher level do the sales and
marketing themselves and not be at the
mercy of the middle however that market
will always exist because guess what a
lot of people are good at sales and
marketing right so there's I wouldn't
worry your young dude I would worry like
your sales skills translates for
everything right 100% I started a
business in swing but I would say that I
would say that make sure you don't
become too transactional
because that's when you become your most
vulnerable yeah Gary what Oh life is
good my man hey Gary what's going on
Danni gold-selling Silicon Valley it's
my dear Rock right here dusty so I have
a youtube channel right now Facebook
channel really right now I'm doing a lot
of just daily vlogs right and so you
know you talk about you know reverse
engineering and and bringing value
disproportionate value to those that
you're that you're trying to market to
as opposed to what you expect to return
and you know right now my business is
doing really well my real estate
business right but I'm looking at this
vlog thing is more of a long-term like
you know personal brand celebrity type
of endeavor right so then you know I
understand how to bring value to my
community per se but then like how as a
daily vloggers will actually bring value
to people that I don't even know that or
they're not in real estate right or debt
or not in the real estate or have no
interest in real estate I think I think
you've only got one move to really be
successful which is to not pander to the
camera and to live your true life and
see if people give a [ __ ] that's the
right answer
right because because either they are or
they aren't but the thing that you need
to trade on is your truth because that's
the thing that's scalable because it's
always there you know fun it is for me
to always just always have to be me it's
super exhausting to try not not be
yourself and it doesn't scale and people
taste it so the reason reality TV worked
was it was a little further than acting
but it's still full of [ __ ]
which is why blogging is better than
reality TV and so and I think the thing
people that you see pop are really in
their zone they're not trying to become
a celebrity for say they want what
celebrity brings which is celebrity is
the number one arbitrage in our society
like it is the number one arbitrage in
our society it's leverage
at scale but I think when people try to
pander to it it comes off so I what my
biggest advice for you man is to just
live your actual life I think the
biggest problem for the modern young
male entrepreneur vlogger personality is
their fronting to a lifestyle that isn't
always true to the reality of what
they're living and then it just gets
convoluted right it's like right you
know like people are starting to already
get called out for like make it pretend
they're taking private flights but
they're not that's hit this right so so
I would give you a really good piece of
ice from somebody who I think really
knows what he's talking about
just live it just with your [ __ ] life
like that you'll be much better thank
you take care dusty holy [ __ ] this is a
dream first I just wanted to take this
opportunity to thank you from the bottom
of my heart express my deepest gratitude
for all the content you put out and just
since I started looking you a couple
months ago - how big of an impact you've
made not only in my business but my life
I think everyone here can attest to that
that's only give you a few ground rules
[Music]
one thing that I've good in paying
attention to you with lately is about
don't listen to what I say watch what I
do yeah
and so for me in business what I'm
trying to do right now is just really
scale and build a great culture and
build a great team awesome so I want to
know what do I need to do to earn the
opportunity to fly out the vaynermedia
for the day and just be a fly on the
wall and shadow you because I just want
to learn and I I just want so bad and
I'm going to do whatever it takes
[Applause]
thank you
I was going Gary buddy you don't get if
you don't have my name is Mike that's
pretty freakin awesome we just did for
that guy you'd probably change life so
I'm a real estate agent within Tarot I
just want to know what how do my
favorite thing about the real estate
industry is the team dynamics right so
so what's the future for real agent you
think we're gonna be taken out by I
don't I don't think so I two moons are
not going anywhere until the robots kill
so so I I think Rick I think one so
here's how I think about it I think
there's a tidal wave of technology
coming I bring that up right but I don't
think it wipes out humans I think it
wipes out humans that decide not to get
their surfboard and jump on it so I
think what's going to happen in real
estate agents is first of all the real
estate industry is fascinating because
it reminds me you know the tech industry
the startup tech world now reminds me a
lot of real estate now that I've been in
it because the real estate industry has
cycles when it's so good that losers win
and and strip it says true and so the
subjects the real estate industry Wall
Street has that the tech industry has it
but it is extreme in real estate because
the crashes are extreme right right so
so I think I would tell you far more
scary to me than what's happening with
technology and real estate is people's
blind belief that it's always going to
be good and they over leveraged
themselves
I'm just so fascinated by am I say over
leveraged there's people that buy up
stuff and you're over leveraged and you
have debt and then there's just people
that are just selling and making
commissions but they're over leveraging
themselves in the way they're treating
their lifestyle like they think it's a
good idea to buy [ __ ] and not save money
as if the market will always be good and
then when the markets not good then and
it's not good
so I think real safe is fine I don't
think there's any major stuff happening
other than I think that the people in
this room that use the new technologies
to build their firm or personal brand
within it are going to
disproportionately outshine people and
the people most worried about are the
people have very good reputations in
their market because that's always been
consistent for the last 100 years that
you can trade on your reputation and
word-of-mouth and I think they don't
realize that the word of mouth is about
the shift to only the digital
environment and so like literally
there's not even going to be an
opportunity for people to like give you
the word of mouth because they're going
to be endorsing people with a share on
Facebook instead of giving your name out
at a barbecue and it's going to happen
faster than people think so that's my
fear it's the people that have tried and
true reputations in their market and
have seen generations before them trade
on that and they got caught because
they're in this moment and six years for
them there's any seven upstarts not one
that is going to take the market from
them we should he carry out really
quickly what's your favorite logic three
ones on these are hours that's why
Bobbi Kristina I I think I think you
know what's interesting before I it's
funny I'm taking about the new album but
he is trapped let me get with different
route with you you know what I really
like about him is why he won and what
I'm trying to get across here Bobby and
Russ and Kyle and all these characters
are winning and they're going to be the
biggest hip hop artists in the world on
everything I've been talking about for
last 20 minutes got it that's
[Applause]
Wow what's up Gary I'm 23 years old
entrepreneur I believe it's in my DNA
and you've really made me question that
so the reason why I wanted to ask you
this question could kind of hold it out
every one of us in this room has to
battle mental strength right Clark when
[ __ ] hits the fan your bank accounts are
negative it's a third failure like what
do you do so we hold on to the optimism
right and I answer on mental strength a
hundred percent especially when your
optimism is blind and doesn't have
practicality wired into it so my
question for you is if you are an
entrepreneur and it's in your DNA and
you listen to your intuition and that's
what gives you your your optimism how do
you how do you create the difference
between mental strength as the source or
intuition is a source you have to make
sure that your intuition is speaking not
your delusion right that's the key and
that's and by the way they're kissing
cousins but yeah so so here's what I
would say I would say that in my
delusion I'm an athlete right like I
want to be I got competitive spirit I'm
a good teeth captain type there's a lot
of things there but but going on to the
playing field I'm going to consistently
lose at the highest levels and can't
make a living doing it so here's what I
would say I don't want you at 23 first
of all at 23 you're golden right you're
golden because you can literally do
nothing right for the next seven years
and still be young as [ __ ]
the old piece of advice I'm going to
give you is do not collect debt and so
if you have already and you have credit
card debt or what have you
do you or don't you I mean minimum pay
RS bug debt yasuno your bells up get rid
of that like go work at [ __ ] 7-eleven
I don't give a [ __ ] get rid of that
get rid of that never buy another thing
in your life and live with 9 dudes and
do your entrepreneurial thing for the
next decade cool
thanks Jay how you going Gary really
good excited to see you Mel why do you
have you a lot of time thank you I have
a brand called next to get next to gets
all about taking action yep um you can't
be next to get unless you take action
yeah so I know you love the gist I do so
I got you a shirt it says next to get to
New York Jay love it I'll wear it give
it to
yeah but I go back make sure to hear you
thank you know much so I know you say
when you get the gist that's going to be
like the worst day of your life but it
actually should be one of the best
because I didn't gotta figure out how to
get to a little v-neck it's super
exaggerated they got to be negative look
I think I think that the reason I say
that is a there's a little truth to it I
think for me no question one of the
reasons I think that I'll be successful
it's really funny that you asked this
question prior to the advice that I just
gave like for me it sounds exciting to
be 23 have no money live in a basement
for seven years and try to do your thing
I genuinely like that because I love the
game right I love the game and so to me
that's what a true bread entrepreneur is
which is it has zero to do with the
stuff it has to do with the game and so
this game that I made up for myself
somewhere around fourth grade to buy
them has been the narrative in the
background for me the whole time and so
there's a little bit of that going away
but at the same token the reason I talk
about it is I don't want people to get
confused I want them to realize that if
you fall in love with the journey that
is the ultimate gift in our lives
because that's just that happiness right
like like we're spending so much time
work like when you actually just get
practical look at the data the amount of
time that you will all spend in your
careers as a percentage to your overall
time on earth is extraordinarily high so
just it's super important to make that
something about more than dollars if
you're unhappy if you're neutral and
money they're awesome I'm just scared of
people that complain that's all I would
tell you that 98% of my advice is for
people that complain why in the world
would I have advice for you if you're
good like you're good
so one thing I have to ask is I would
love to be able to meet with you and
maybe you can become a mentor or
business partner I know you can help me
there's no shot I gotta ask
I got a have it got asked I just thing
on that sandwich I use like that dude
that got lucky and guess got the first
thing and it's going to come to visit a
Newark lousy him for forty four point
eight seconds that's are you know like
suddenly turned into nineteen minutes or
might turn into four hours but like I
never want to [ __ ] somebody want
then the one thing I don't have is time
guys time is everything it's why it's
why the mobile device is so important
it's saving you time time let me on it
next to get take me on I will go Gary um
how are you feeling today phenomenal
that's great to hear
um it's awesome just talking to you I've
been following your content for the last
year or so and you taught me what hustle
really was I thought I was working I've
been I own my business for last four
years I'm 20 years old now so I started
speaking on team suicide prevention on
16 um after some experience I went
through and right now I'm really growing
my media and I'm really focusing on
being a media company
so I started podcasting and the question
I have is with daily vlogging so this
might also be rough might jump in but
I'm logistical II thinking of daily
vlogging and what's the process of
getting of your daily vlog getting up on
YouTube do you post it the day after you
film it isn't the Negri we've done a
bunch of stuff I think the first couple
of weeks it took us like three days then
we went through a period of a long
period of doing it the next day okay uh
and now we're like on a two-day delay
even though we have more people and
indie-rock went through a hardcore year
of like filming the whole thing and then
having to edit and getting it out the
next day I think you can do anything I
mean I think I think you can't [ __ ]
yourself right
my buddy Casey stop vlogging so the next
day is like I'm in a vlog every day to
pick up the thing but then literally in
my blog yesterday I was like you know
the summer is coming I feel like I need
a little more time with my family and
don't want to be thinking about
producing
content so maybe I won't like I think
it's it's about reverse engineering what
you can get done and for me you know
only two years ago three years ago there
was three people on my team making
content you know it took me four years
to build up vaynermedia to have one
person work with me on my content prior
to that it was just me and now I'm at 15
I mean you built you building you do
different things and so I think um I
think the processes as fast being
[ __ ] 10 okay so do you think its
value if you think a daily vlog is
valuable enough over something like
sales I do a lot of sales to high
schools colleges conferences this is a
classic branding versus sales right
right I think you need to sell at the
most minimum to make you whole for
whatever you need pay your bills right
um so that but and then invest as much
as you can in building your brand so
media comes after sales you would
recommend you better pay your [ __ ]
bills bro
exactly well right now I'm living at
home well then your [ __ ] smart yeah
so to me now it just becomes a question
of how much money you want my big
recommendation listen I only give advice
that I took myself mm-hmm I'm a big fan
of that I took over my family liquor
store business and I grew up from a
three at this at this window that I'm
talking about from a three to a forty
five million dollar business in my early
20s right I'm 27 years old I build a
forty five million dollar business and I
was paying myself thirty seven thousand
dollars a year but I wasn't a typical
dude that needed money as a leverage to
get girls exactly I don't not the thing
is I don't need a lot of money right now
so I'm wondering what does it build
myself up as a speaker without really
worrying about the sales aspect of it
all sort of course right and as you say
that I think that's a guarantee what say
it I hear your head I hear your voice in
my head sometimes I think Gary Vee would
say that
time to dream about you answering my
Ashley I had a question earlier last
night I dreamed about you answering my
question I guess your closet is so
effective now off of that little story
watch what I'm doing not what I'm saying
yes
you got it got it thank you so much one
hi Gary B first I want to say thank you
again everything all of your podcasts
all of your videos on YouTube are kind
of my real education College wishes the
paperwork I am a marketing manager for a
nonprofit organization which is a unique
position that I'm very fortunate to have
now part of my job and it's a new job is
I'm building up our presence on social
media I have three different target
audiences and I have the women we serve
about the volunteers and donors yep my
question to you is does it make sense to
use one platform or each platform but
one account right one account to target
all Jenny okay instead of focusing on
one platform per group yes because the
way we consume content in social is not
binary the content flying to it needs to
find it's not email 1996 where people
been up 90 percent of their email
it's got it it's just one feed we don't
even know who the [ __ ] is coming from
you're looking at the content not the
little logo that's delivering it got it
yes thank you you're welcome
[Applause]
hi Barry my name is Jon first of all
it's a dream come true six months ago I
wrote it down I'm going to be Gary
Vaynerchuk and Here I am right now good
ship it's awesome and then I met Danny
more L want to thank Danny real quick
for having their vision and clarity for
making you happy
I'm with inter-row State so the best
it's actually my first week in real
estate and I'm super excited I'm
door-knocking my question is what were
you doing last week what's that what
were you doing last week I was hauling a
door knocking and hustling and I'm doing
Facebook live I'm doing videos all this
stuff but my question is when your
parents is saying when you bring the
clients or talk about the clients that
oh you don't know what you're talking
about
oh you have to make sure all this stuff
is correct so what if it embarrasses off
what would you say to that well I would
say your parents are probably right a
lot more than you realize right if I was
in real estate for the first week right
what I would probably do so like I'm now
actually super interested in watching
one of your facebook lives because
because what I'm curious about is are
you faking it til you make it or are you
documenting the journey of a young man
trying to learn the industry my
intuition is number one what I would do
what I would do if I was in week one how
many people what team were you on again
let me tell the people that wound again
me if I was standing there I would
straddle up real close to all those
willing people and spend and spend one
year shutting the [ __ ] up and listening
me
then you'll know what it says you're not
going to lose your charisma and
showmanship you're a baby you just don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
I have a follow-up question should I
keep doing Instagram
stories just documenting and dude I
think it's far more interesting it was
the advice I gave that other young man
tell your truth a lot you know you may
lose a lot of people were like I'm not
going with this dude on his third week
but if you're actually running a
marathon in six years
you could have everybody who's buying
their first house okay appreciate it I
think I think you know now I'm gonna
pander to the crowd how many people over
40 right so the thing that I think is
super interesting for me for everybody
that just raised your hand
nothing's changed like like technology
is not going to allow bad things to all
the sudden populate right like liked
riding through is tried and true all the
technology is doing is exposing things
you guys haven't changed because of all
this technology
you've just been exposed hey Gary hey
thank you so much for being here and
Dani I'm really excited I saw a video
that you're doing the other day about
success and that somebody who's
entrepreneur and makes $150,000 that's a
lot higher form of success than someone
who's you know nine-to-five not doing
what they want hey Carolyn yeah no not
being a job or an entrepreneur my
trading desk is unhappiness uh-huh my
point there was if you're making 150,000
a year at being a lawyer and you're not
pumped or you could be making ninety
eight thousand a year selling slime on
Instagram but it's your dream because
you love making spine with your
eight-year-old I think it's a worthwhile
debate I'm just blown away by people
that are literally willing to buy
narrowly be dramatically less happy for
an extra eight thousand dollars so they
can go on a [ __ ] cruise bro
so so my question was based on on that
Billy action there yeah what what how
should people be thinking about their
success you also talk about Natural Born
entrepreneurs like you as much as you
would want to be LeBron you know that
takes a certain amount of natural talent
so what what can you speak about success
and the role that patience plays in that
instead of that what are you asking me
what's your situation my situation is
I'm new right I'm listening to
everything that you're saying data
sometimes don't go well so I'm like okay
I'm gonna turn i'ma turn on Gary Vee see
what you have to say try to get some
golden nuggets and I want to know a big
thing that you talk about is patience
and that role that that plays when
you're young and you're starting and and
so I wanted to kind of hear what you say
so I could kind of like rapidly like put
that in who are you playing this game
for is super interesting to me
I want tough things that a lot of young
people in this room have if they've got
chips on their shoulders because they
want to prove their mom wrong because
they want to prove that their older
sister isn't the only star in the family
you know where I'm going with this is
very simply almost everybody in this
room is living their lives to the judge
and jury of somebody outside of
themselves and that [ __ ] blows and so
where I'm going with you is there's a
lot of questions I'd like to ask but the
first one is for what and for who the
reason I win you know there's a scene
it's really funny because I was born in
Russia and the stuff in the former
Soviet Union there's a scene in Rocky
4 where Drago loses at the end but he
takes the mic and he's like [ __ ] he eats
talks and Russian sister he was
basically saying [ __ ] you Russia that
wanted me to be sis America I was
fighting for myself I was in this ring
for myself the reason a winning young
man is because I'm in this ring for
myself I don't give a [ __ ] anybody says
about me nobody
now back back back is Celeste that has
nothing to do with me
that has to do with my DNA compounded by
extremely strong parenting and
environment right so I don't say that as
I'm cool I'm telling you my truth and
I'm trying to get as many people as
close to that as possible because I
don't have the answers for you but what
I can tell you is if you do it for
yourself if you're judging yourself [ __ ]
gets real easy lives of zero bad days
because I'm in that binary place of
knowing my intent and doing what I do
and then the only thing that can drag me
down is outside forces around the health
of my family and friends and luckily for
me the far majority of those days aren't
going to be the critical days where I
lose some of that right that's it
they're like what are you trying to do
is it about the money is about proving
something to somebody because if you're
trying to prove it to yourself you'll be
a whole life to do that if it a whole
life to do that guys like a lot of you
know I love football let's call it a
hunt 80 years it's getting better even
closer to 90 just breaking down in four
quarters like you really this is why I
hate flashing 25 year old young
entrepreneurs do you really want to be
up 21 nothing in the second quarter and
reuse 37 to 28
because you're sure acting like it so
that's what I'm intrigued by bro so what
am I asking the questioner and that's it
have you ever done some juice you figure
out yeah alright last question I do a
video every day 30 seconds or less with
people on their favorite quotes got to
do with them with you before we leave
yep
yes all right thank you sure thank you
so much Michu didn't realize I was
coming too right hook on no good so I'm
not a real estate agent I own my own
clothing company my company turns five
yesterday Congrats thank you
and we're a wholesale company and my
target audience actually is women over
40 okay um and we and we yeah although
female over 44 the [ __ ] we're full
film and we sell to a bunch of different
stores and we are very successful in
fulfill and are you doing are you doing
direct consumer yes we have a very small
part of our business only about 5% our
business at sold comm or partner
challenge yes our challenge is our
demographic buying online
I know snapchat in a trance but younger
generations they buy online you know
you're probably out of your mind right
like completely well we we've done
surveys we asked our customers buck your
furs I'm trying to figure out what the
best platform is for my age great look
and converting that to a facebook store
or selling it driving them to you're
calm like do you know which fashion is
sold to forty to sixty year old women in
e-commerce in this country a lot okay
because you just told me your demos it's
not doing that do you know what I mean
you just make you might not know how to
do that
that's my sound I don't know
[Music]
Elkind yes we know that part but on the
refill end of it it's just trying to
figure out what any apps you need to
invest your money into bringing somebody
who has a.com direct-to-consumer fashion
female background and let her or him be
your director of EECOM
direct-to-consumer and go do your thing
you're you're in a your you're making it
convenient to your strengths and
weaknesses which is the quickest way to
go out of business that's not you know
what I mean planning so I think you know
that I can tell so I you know I don't
know your business but I would make a
little less money and immediately hire
somebody who can flat out and call
references go hire somebody who's sold
you know to that lovely lady on the
internet you know and hire them and then
site and then and then when you hire
them don't go okay great I got Ricky or
Sally and go do your thing we get real
[ __ ] close and you site than that
information now cuz it's your [ __ ]
company and you don't want that to grow
to 38 percent of your business and then
Rick's got all the [ __ ] leverage and
I bless ya last question guys last
question sorry everybody in line sorry
he's a real dick
hey my name is Ella sir thank you for
the motivation I actually think I look
up to you because I'm also an immigrant
and you give me a good example that
success can actually be reached no
matter where you come from so thank you
immigrants have the advantage they
really do I really I'm by the way
American born people dominate but the
advantage is we know the alternative my
kids are [ __ ] going to be losers like
you know you know it's just hard when
you've got it and don't work for it so
I'm glad that's the case but I want you
to realize how good a bit advantage you
actually have yeah actually my name is
brothers actually told me all that time
all the time so they say well you just
work harder because you're an immigrant
you have the immigrant mentality I
actually look them dead in the face and
say that's right [ __ ]
IMAX I'm actually recording it right now
genuine success and then also tell them
that you're also working smarter now
what dick it's all right here
I hate that [ __ ] argument Gary yeah
it's cool you hustle but I work smart me
too dick face now what ya do both so
here's my situation I I recently started
a business on my own um thank you and so
it's been going pretty well it's a
retail business
it's a brick-and-mortar business and I
know that you actually talk about how
brick and mortars are possibly going out
of business soon if their economics are
too tied into unrealistic leases and
they don't have alternatives right so
it's remember how I said like everything
everything in media can work its what's
under price and over price retail is not
going to die people it just retails are
not going to pay eighty seven dollars a
square foot when the way we buy now it
should be sixty one got it
and instead of spending their money on
fixtures they may allocate twenty five
percent of their space for you to drink
coffee or for a band to be there they're
gonna need to draw they have to change
it's all about change so that's that's
what's on my mind keep going
so my thing is I have an opportunity now
be
other businesses do well to expand into
a second location which is also
brick-and-mortar but my I'm not a piece
of ice yeah make whatever projections
you have or whatever your business is
currently doing just siphon out 20% of
it like just make pretend you lost 20%
of it and if the math works then go for
it
okay got it just anticipate the decline
the 20% decline is that over that's my
intuition at the macroeconomic climates
of what retail is doing will affect you
you may not even ever feel that you may
feel 50% of it but you can't be blunt
morning sell I sell the disciplines yeah
[ __ ] man
like like like people buy that [ __ ] of
scale on the internet so like don't get
[ __ ] crazy like you know like keep
that in mind yeah so I sell this stuff
online as well so my question was
whether I should take the second
brick-and-mortar store and continue
doing business online or if I should
just take that full lump of money that I
would invest into a brick-and-mortar
store which got me here in the first
place and just take it all and invested
in my e-commerce what gets you somewhere
is irrelevant to where you're going
sorry
so I think we know the answer we don't
need to pay homage to that [ __ ] store
that got you there gotcha okay and then
the other question too is kind of
interesting no no no no that's it Oh dr.
Cody was a dick oh well thank you thank
you you know what gold digger because I
like that one more go thank you buddy
Gary you made me you helped me realize
that I need to quit my job selling cars
so I can actually go into business for
myself so I'd like to thank you for that
and I really like seriously my no get up
get up here come on you can come on you
can ask go ahead oh oh oh you're taking
a picture got it okay
hi I'm Kerry oh my gosh okay I came down
here from Northern California just to
say thank you for all of the all the
content you put out cuz I found you when
I was at a really tumultuous part of my
life and my life just being like fully
accountable and just just not going for
perfect just getting my myself just
getting it done and just making micro
adjustments is just quantifiably made my
life so much better and I just wanted to
say thank you awesome
regalia applause everybody
so hold on I got off I gotta tell you
guys a little story you know it was it
was kind of awesome because uh you know
I last night I highly respect this kind
of and tell you why because you know I
had this illusion that I mean I know he
says he works hard but I mean I didn't
really understand how hard he worked so
I'm thinking if I'm gonna do an event
I'm gonna fly in the night before you
know relax hang out for a little bit
wake up the next day maybe I do a little
workout you know what I'm saying and
maybe do some work in the room and then
when it's time for me to speak then I
come up and speak you know that that's
normal right well last night I noticed
on his Instagram story I'm like [ __ ]
he's not on an airplane yet and then
this this morning you know I'm stressing
I was like the money one two right there
was a lot of money right and I'm certain
I'm watching d-roc and I'm watching
Garen I'm watching both of them and
they're still not like on their way to
the airport right and then it was like
literally like 10 o'clock a.m. and I
finally see you guys all your way to the
airport I get offstage and the dudes are
literally walking in from taking maybe a
three minute shower we sit down our
podcast and you know afterwards we're
just kind of shooting the [ __ ] and the
podcast is done which went fantastic by
the way and I go so what's up what are
you guys are doing answer but you know
I'm ready to like invite them to my
house to come barbecue and now have a
party relax he goes or I'm gonna hop on
a plane I got a red-eye like the guy
literally woke up this morning got on a
plane flew here talked for a little bit
is going to get on a plane and go back
like that's with jet people oxygen prism
Rama comes back
thank you take a read I land in New York
drive an hour in New York early-morning
traffic take a quick shower and then go
do a 11-hour day and then hop on a
flight and fly to Ghana oh I'm up
pensively promise I'm part of a
nonprofit called pencil promise so I'm
going to go build some schools check out
what we're doing
yeah definitely I also say something I
want to take a moment to say thank you
to all of you guys because you know I
know Gary Vee represents something
different to each and every one of you
guys but for for me personally what it
represents is is a sign of my intense
commitment to go all in to go all right
and I want to say that I say that it's
to go all in and all of you and all in
our journey together and all in in the
growth that we're about to have so I'm
going to commit right now
he's gonna come back I'm gonna on Monday
call the agency book them again for next
year do you're not crazy
yeah no no no I'm gonna do that now do I
know the prices going up all right
arbitrage arbitrage and then lastly if
everybody gets a damn picture I want a
picture so let's do a huge selfie
everybody sounds good everybody give it
up for Gary B
[Applause]
[Music]